stand-up is not supposed to be sexy no
no when i do it baby
[Laughter]
what's up with lebanese people in hairy
arms
hey don't give away my material bro
that's half my egg
no i don't think i don't think it's
supposed to be sexy
it's not i don't think even especially
especially girls when they do something
like stand up and they do sexy they get
hate from both sides yeah the girl hate
on them and the guy that are with the
girl that are hating hate on them
because like i can't be like that girl
look good next to that girl that hates
her yeah because she looks good because
then i'm gonna hear it i'm gonna be
honest all night
if you're attractive i don't think
that's a lot of people yeah yeah and
like when i say attractive i don't mean
like oh this guy's kind of tall or this
girl's kind of she has some big i mean
like actually you know what the thing is
like what's that girl elijah schlinger
schlesinger
yeah yeah yeah
you ain't seen the chest on that her yo
she's attractive for sure for sure she
i would probably say stand up she's the
most attractive yeah
and you don't take it seriously
but like who cares what i think i mean
i'm just someone i understand but if you
ask me like
you know obviously she's done her job so
it doesn't work but i mean if i'm at a
comedy club or i'm an open mic for
whatever reason i got to buy something
or it's like the dane cooks
right yeah like
basically the dude
yeah the backstreet boy he was a
backstreet boy he was a basketball and
he turned out to be a fraud later on you
know you know even though you had some
good bits or whatever but i don't know
for whatever
there's a bias there you say for
whatever reason it's not because you
don't think they struggled
enough because you think they have like
that pretty privilege so there's no
struggle in adsense so it's like what
have you lived that's gonna be so funny
about [ __ ] you look good you're like a
[ __ ] that's super funny it's
like ellen
but ellen wasn't rich rich but that's
just someone that starts doing comedy
like t.i and he starts doing comedy when
he's a rapper i'm like i can't take this
[ __ ]
like you don't you don't need this it
could and it could be not like like you
said it's a bias but i understand what
like for me where the bias is from it's
like what have you struggled
yeah it's not that they don't struggle i
think you're just you're in i feel like
comedians have to be are generally
outsiders
so they observe from the outside that's
where they make their lives yeah that's
my purpose and most of the communities
that i know of
have appeared that way either people got
stuffed in locker rooms or got bullied
by other people
that was like that's like the meta for
yeah
i know they're looking for months
outside yeah yeah i mean look at the top
communities
they all look like troglodytes right and
that's okay i'm not made of it but there
is a certain pattern there so for
whatever reason because i'm used to that
pattern if i see someone who's out of
that meta it's like i don't know
something seems off about that yeah
that's what you're saying i can't
understand that's been pretty consistent
for me i can understand yeah and i think
what keeps coming in going is needing
that validation
yes because the one time where you feel
like an outsider not just an outsider
but a [ __ ] cult leader is when you're
on stage
and they all listen
[ __ ] i don't get that anywhere else i
know i don't yeah i don't get that
nowhere else and so you go back up on
stage looking for that but if an
attractive person say you're already
kind of adorned in a way